volumetric spanners in all
notes thank hi everyone uh so yeah I'm
going to talk about tight balance for
volumetric spanners in all norms and you
will shortly see what this means and
this is a joint work uh with AAS
and okay uh so this is basically the
problem we are considering so we are
given a set of vectors let's say V1 to
VN in a d
dimensional space and they goal is to
find some bases for for this uh set of
points such that um I can write every
point in the input as a linear
combination of the vector in the
bases uh in a way that the coefficients
in my this linear combination uh are
small so meaning that here the absolute
value if I write v as the sum of alpha I
VI for the vi in the bases the absolute
value of alpha I are as small
and I would like to have the bases uh as
small as possible so the size we need to
make it as small as
possible so this is basically the
general idea and actually nothing
prevents of of looking only at the
absolute value or uh L Infinity Norms of
the coefficient vector and we can think
of any um any Norm of the coefficient
vectors so that that's the goal so I
would like to come with a base with a
small uh coefficient U Norm for all
points in the input and the size of uh
base I needed to be as a small as
possible so is the problem
clear and it actually seems I mean
uh it seems to be very important problem
in a sense that people have uh discover
rediscovered several times and it has
been used in various uh applications so
I mean back in uh
1929 uh that was a basis defined by
Arbok and basically what it I mean it
was in terms of in context of uh
functional analysis and it's a different
language
or more somewhat maybe uh Stronger
result in general but what it imply here
is that for any compact set in a d
dimensional space is a basis of size d
such that the L Infinity Norms of the
coefficient uh is less than
one okay and actually it was I mean
since it was very useful concept it was
somewhat uh rediscovered in this
learning theory
community and they use it for linear
optimization problem and multi-arm
Bandit problems and they call it
actually bicentric
spanners okay so this is uh basically
can we uh think of um volumetric spanner
with L Infinity Norm this is basically
what they're doing and they show that
there exist a order size d and basically
for instance the application in online
linear optimizational multiarm andand it
was basically finding a basis for the
exploration space
and um yeah and just try to optimizing
the results using that basis okay
and later it was also I mean this term
was uh proposed by hazan carne in Mecca
and Haan
Carin uh where they also studied this uh
object or Concept in for multiarm Bandit
and now even experimental design and
some more uh Matrix related
problem and now they consider it with
respect to the L2 Norm so they would
like to minimize the to make sure that
the L2 Norms of the coefficient Vector
for all Vector for all points in the
input is a
small and so I mean just to Define it
more formally again so we are given a
set of Point V1 to VN and you would like
to find a subset of them specified by S
I mean it's the
indices such that I mean all points can
be written in as a linear combination of
just the points in the in this spanner
and L2 Norm is less than
one
okay uh
and the thing that they showed is that
there exist for for any
um for any set of points of I mean let's
say for any n vectors you can find at
most uh 12 time
d uh bases in time polinomial in n and
D okay then actually they show some
existential result for any convex body
so it's here I mean it's they can
efficiently compute it but even for more
I mean uh General case they can show
that there exists such a
basis okay and actually they rais as an
open question with um so they they they
they show that there exists a a
volumetric spanner of size 12 * D and
it's there is some lower bound that's
showing that you need at least D+ one so
and it was a question that what's what's
the right answer and or I mean if you
can just shrink the
Gap okay okay and it doesn't stop here
so again it was also studied in this
concept I mean this notion like what
they called well conditioned basis
spanning subset and it was basically
used for because of I mean its
application in Matrix sketching low rank
approximation and this problem by the
scoop. all and actually very recently in
this stock this year
uh David woodro and Ty yasuda they
used volumetric spanner or what they
call spanning subset to improve a host
of a u problem in Matrix is sketching I
mean several problem related to low rank
approximation Columns of selection and
so
on okay and let's let me just again I
mean Define what they're uh using so
they're
saying uh we have a set of vector we
want to be n we would like a volume what
they call I mean spanning subset they
call it the c a spanning subset which is
a subset of vectors in the input so that
I can write any any point in the input
as a linear combination of the points uh
in the spanning subset and the L2 Norms
is at most
C so I mean you can think of C anything
uh for for their application it was like
1 plus Epsilon or
something and the way I mean they
actually somewhat just use it as a black
box in a sense and they got it from the
corset result for John ellipsoid from
this result by
Todd and in some sense I mean it's uh uh
it was some uh
I mean the Haan and Haan atal got a
better result I mean in sense of the
size was order D but in their
construction they could get a spanning
subset of size d log log D but in a
better around
time okay but there are I mean many
application that the size is important
so maybe it's better to replace with
this order D
size okay and actually I mean the main
contribution in their work they show
that there are many many applications
for this volumetric
expan um no no yeah it's just actually
plus nnz so
yeah what do you mean so by the you mean
the exact the relation or yes so number
of nonzero entries do you take that to
some power also no no no I
just fair with all algorithm yeah but
it's just plus eny yeah thanks yeah
thanks
um we need to assume like all of our
vectors have the same Norm or something
or it doesn't matter not really I mean
if you have a I mean large Vector that
could actually help you in the so if I
have a long Vector I would pick that and
it would make the coefficient of every
yeah that that can actually help in some
sense right but yeah but it also works
if all are scaled that's I
mean nor bound the norm one or
something okay yeah and actually I
mention there are tons of application I
just mention a few of them here and they
can use this uh spanning subset or
volumetric spanner and get improv bounds
for them and actually they show for in
online version of this problem okay but
I'm not going to talk about the
application I'm focusing on the
volumetric spanner itself here and in
particular I'm going to show that the
local search simple local search
algorithm get tight bounds for
volumetric
spanner so we show that if you just run
local search algorithm with the with a
correct somewhat update rule then you
get a spanner of volumetric spanner of
size at most 3 times d uh in polinomial
time and the local St is very simple
it's just a single
Swap okay and actually I mean we are
addressing in some sense right this
question by hazan and Carney so we are
shrinking the
Gap and in compared to the prior works
so compared to the hazan tall I mean
there we are we are faster and so
actually we didn't try to really
optimize the the runtime but I mean even
just a simple implementation is just DS
Square faster um but I mean the main
uh the main thing is that our algorithm
is much simpler compared to this so I
mean to get a sense I mean they use a
spectral sparsification by Batson
Spielman Shava and it's a very heavy
machinery and they need to keep track of
barrier potential function and then do
some rounding afterwards so it's quite a
heavy machinery they're using for
that and actually I mean they themselves
also had some simpler construction for
volumetric spanner which used the order
d Times log D log n i mean they actually
the Simplicity was actually important
even for them so this is important to
come up because as it's many application
and I mean it's they want it to be just
simple enough to be uh use an
application they actually desire for
something simple as
well okay and just compared to the to
the just recent lineup work by uh wraf
suda and Todd I mean they're losing a
factor of log log
t Okay so that's I mean the clear I mean
the size in this construction is
better and another thing is that we can
show that this local search is actually
almost optimal for all Norms it's not um
for L2 Norm or L infinity and somewhat I
mean just a single thing that works for
everything um and in particular just to
but but I mean it works for all Norms
but uh the complexities are
somewhat very different in different
yeah the lower bound shown was basically
D Simplex or the one uh yeah I think so
yeah
yeah yeah we don't yeah it's not any
fancy lower one
so okay good so yeah so when we have P
when p is equal to one we can show
actually um there's somewhat simple
argument I'll will uh go to it further
in in the talk that even if you just not
pick one of the points uh in the input
then you have then the L1 Norm of
coefficient can get as large as uh
square root n and n here itself is
exponential in D okay so
um you cannot get really the L1 Norm
down to one so you have to pay almost a
square the number of the
things okay um and actually we we can we
can get a matching bound here as well by
just using the search and for one and
two we can also now use the result from
P equal to 1 and P equal to two to get
this upper bound and lower bound results
so lower bound and upper bound
result
um and I mean we're just using holder
inequality and so on and for p greater
than two it's also easy that just the L2
is spanner imply something for LPS
spanner right so the when when the L2
Norm is less than one for sure I mean LP
Norm is less than one so the size is
still uh by by the size of the spanner
for L2 volumetric uh spanner we get we
get the same Bound for LP
volumetric okay and actually I mean
among one of the application that
uh wanted to highlight is minimum volume
in closing ellipsoid or J
ellipsoid and this is basically saying
so you you are given a symmetric convex
body K and what we the mve or minimum
volume enclosing ellipsoid is the
ellipsoid that the minimum volume
ellipsoid that contains U contains
K okay and we show that actually um this
local search also gives some uh core set
for this problem so we can pick a set of
uh points of sze order D over Epsilon
such that um the volume of the uh input
is less than 1 plus Epsilon to the power
raised to the power D times the volume
of the uh mve of
s
okay and just to give uh a little bit
about this as well I mean this is
somewhat this is uh this is somewhat
related to these contact points of
convex bodies
and I mean that's a bit strong stronger
notion actually of that what we are
showing here than what we showing here
for instance there is this result by
rudal son and which was improved by
Shira that show that for any uh for any
convex body K you can find another one
Edge such that it's a contact point with
the MV with John ellip so is a small and
basically it's order of the overson the
square and this basically also imply a
coret for MV some sense
and so so we we knew that but it's just
order of D over Epsilon
square and also I mean the prior works
that uh actually got this uh well
condition based or uh or a spanning
subset they rely
on uh minimum volume and closing
ellipsoids and their result for instance
from the Todd its result the size was
something like d log log D plus d over
Epsilon and in the prior work it was
like order of DS square or Epsilon
actually I mean the prior work in this
line of research they use mve to design
volumetric spanner but somewhat here I
mean we are doing a reverse thing so we
are showing that the local search is is
giving a good volumetric spanner and it
also implies a good uh
MV do you improve the contact point no
no I mean it's a stronger right so it's
basically saying that uh if you look at
the mve and just scale it by 1 plus
Epsilon it will contain K but our result
only can compare the
volume it doesn't say that strong
condition no
that yeah so exactly this a weaker
notion compared to that contact Point
thing um but it's similar exactly to the
the course of definition defined by Todd
and this prior work and actually that's
for them it was enough for them to get
this volumetric uh volumetric spanner
guarantee okay actually I mean just
conceptually interesting if you think
about some much simpler object like uh
if you are given a set of point and want
to find a axis parallel bounding box of
this point you need also two D manying
points we just need to pick the extreme
points along each axis and that's the
basically a corset for axis parallel
bounding box so in what in some sense I
mean we are looking at the ellipsoid but
the corset size is uh is still the same
as I mean this very simple
object and one thing is that
um in our approach and actually maybe
even I think also the earlier approach
uh you can cannot hope for
some uh strong type corset and it's
actually maybe interesting I mean which
is also related again to contact point
so again could be the case that we can
preserve mve but if we look at some
ellipsoid for the corset like this I
mean these black points are are my are
are are the point in my coret but if I
look at one ellip soid that contains
them even if I scale them by some large
constant factor I may not be able to
cover everything I
think so uh it's a bit
different okay and again I mean just to
complete the contribution we can use our
volumetric spanner as a black box and
just improve the bounce here uh using
the results of uh David and
tyuk okay now let's uh go to local
search any questions so far
okay so I promis you that the algorithm
is very simple and that's basically the
algorithm so this is the input we are we
are given a set of points
n and we just need some accuracy
parameter Delta and the size parameter R
which is larger than D and R is going to
be the number
of vectors that I put in my uh
volumetric spanner and then I just
output the volumetric spanner of size
R okay so it has just uh uh these steps
I initialize it
um with with the with a set of vectors
and initial has two parts so the first
part is that I just pick D vectors in s
by the greedy algorithm for volume
maximization and add them to my um
spanner and then for the rest which is R
minus D I just arbitr pick some vectors
from the
input okay and then I work with this
Matrix which is just out of product of
the vectors in the spanner and go
through a local search algorithm and in
each step I try I check whether there
exists um a vector in my set in my
spanner that I can swap it with someone
else out of it such that the determinant
of M minus VI I VI transpose plus VJ VJ
transpose get uh larger by factor of 1
plus Delta compared to determinant of
M that's uh the thing and if it was the
case I just make the Swap and
continue okay so just first of all
without loss of generality we can assume
that the vectors are of rank D otherwise
we can just focus on the span of the uh
input so for now I mean we know that
there Frank D um
and okay and one one more thing so if
you're familiar with this local search
algorithm of uh Madan at all so they're
using similar local search but for a
different context of DET terminal
maximization I mean it's very natural I
mean we also only just dealing with DET
terminal
here okay so now I'm going to show you
first of all why it's running polinomial
time but terminat uh next I will show
you the the guarantee or the
approximation guarante for volumetric
spanner why the coefficients are always
less than one uh when I'm using this set
of
vectors okay so for round runtime
analysis so the thing that I'm going to
do is I'm going to keep track of the
determinant of M I show that initially
it has a good value at each step I'm
just increasing by some Factor constant
factor and the optimal thing cannot be
too large that's the plan so so I mean
in each iteration I make sure that it's
increased by factor of 1 plus Delta
that's simple so I need to bound uh the
initial determinant so why initially I
get something
reasonable at least for my purpose and
that's actually U comes from the greedy
the guarantee of the greedy
algorithm so let's try to bound the
determinant of M or M in it uh the
initial M and for that let's TS star
b b be a subset of size d in the vector
in the input that uh the its alter
product has the maximum the
terminal okay and let's G be be the set
that it's returned by theg the algorithm
of the Cal magnetus
file okay so by just it's a very simple
I mean we can write the determinant of
uh the initial Matrix M by question a
formula as just the termin as sum of sub
subd determinants of size d and in
particular we have just one of them
corresponding to the
greedy and this is uh already larger
than one over uh the factorial I think
I'm missing
a power of two here so one / D factorial
raised to the power of T times
determinant of the best uh uh subd
determinant of size d here corresponding
to TS
star okay and this is just the guarantee
of the greedy
algorithm okay so I have some bounds for
the initialization and I also need to
bound just the determinant of the the
maximum determinant of any of subset of
size R Ms star and this also very
similar so again I use the question a
formula this is the
bound
right and now I mean since uh I know
that the number of terms here is R
choose D and each subd determinant is
less than just the max determinant with
the D vectors denoted by T
star so then I get the bounce all right
so I get this bounce for the optimum and
I get this Bound for determinant of the
initial Matrix
M and since I in each step I increase by
factor of 1 plus Delta this is just a
number of iterations B * log R uh over
Delta okay and actually I mean the
computation for each iteration if you
just do it naively and do not do
anything like sketching or something we
get just n * R time d s so that would be
then the total run time would be
something like uh and I mean r is also
order D is more more or less like n d to
the power 4 but if you do some sketching
you can actually uh get better
dependence you can get rid of n for
instance and get some
uh nnz of the A and so
on
okay so any question for the WR time
analysis I think it should be
clear
good so now let's see maybe actually the
uh more important question so why why
after after the algorithm terminates I
get the the result that I wanted so I
have the coefficient vectors uh with the
small Norms L2 Norms let's say
so this is actually what uh I will have
when the algorithm terminates right then
I know that for every
J uh that is not that that it uh that is
not in the spanner I cannot swap it with
anyone in the spanner and uh get uh
improve the determinant by 1 plus
Delta but my goal is that to show that
if I look at the Matrix whose columns
are vector s in s then for any points VJ
or any Vector VJ there exists a
coefficient Vector Alpha J such that U
Alpha J is equal to VJ and the L2 Norm
of alpha J is less than one and this is
my
goal okay so first of all let's see if
we can get a bounds for Alpha J here so
so in general if I write the alpha if I
want to solve for Alpha J here I can
just take this uh minimum Norm solution
uh us to the inverse time VJ and if I
compute now the norm of alpha J here is
basically VJ transpose uu transpose
inverse VJ I mean which I just writed uh
it would be VJ transpose m to the power
my I mean M inverse VJ which I Define it
as T J is also I mean leverage scores
and sense so basically that's
interesting right I mean the the the
object that
I'm I need to work with is is basically
related to what I'm uh keeping track in
in the
algorithm and we'll see how we can now
relate these two
values okay so I'll talk so I mean this
is this we should then I'll work Define
the t i as just VI transpose M Inver M
uh inverse VI and t i j as VI transpose
M inverse
VJ so I mean these are the leverage
scores for the I in the spanner set for
instance
um actually they have some nice
properties for instance the sum of these
T is equal to D and they're also
symmetric T J is equal to T
[Applause]
ji okay so now let's let's check again
the condition that we have so we stop at
this point I mean if the determinant of
this object is is not more than 1 plus
Delta times determinant of M then we
just stop the local search and we can
actually simplify the left hand side and
write it as determinant of M * 1 minus t
i * 1 plus T J plus t i j squar and it's
actually not that hard we are using this
some Matrix determinant LMA and Sherman
morison formula you can get you can get
that bound okay but now everything looks
very good I mean there in terms of t i t
j and these are the thing that I want to
show the uh are bounded so that I can
show that the um L2 Norm of the
coefficient Vector is
bounded okay so that was the uh what I
wanted to
show and to see that I mean this is what
we have for every J not in the spanner
and every I in the spanner I know that
this
holds and then for fix J just sum over
all I in the spanner I'll get this the
things for the left hand side and right
right hand side just become simply R * 1
plus Delta and if you just do the
calculation we get basically to J is
less than D plus r Delta over R minus D+
one and setting the value for instance R
to 3D and Delta to one over uh 3 we get
the L2 Norm uh less than one for
everyone not in this
spanner Okay so actually I mean I just
described the local
search
um when I don't allow for repetition but
but I could do that as well I mean you
can also run it with with repetition and
then we will have this result for
everyone but but here for the case of
volumetric spanner I mean we actually
don't need to do it with repetition and
just we don't allow repetition for
volumetric expan but later for mve I
mean it's important that we allow a
repetition
quick question so I mean so
existentially now you could get a
stronger result right don't you get like
2D uh so if I put Delta equals zero so
my algorithm runs until it cannot okay
right you get you get a 2d size I
existential and then that matches your
founding yeah
yeah we care a lot of about the wrong
time we
shouldn't okay uh so let's see what it
gets for volumetric spanner um so I just
described the algorithm for p equal 2
right so I mean you just run the local
search and it finds all to a spanner of
size at small 3D in in polinomial around
time but that's a good point I mean we
show also that there exist a 2d
one and for p equal to one I said that
it's actually uh completely different
from the case for p equal
2 uh to see that I mean there's a very
canonical uh somewhat uh construction
just consider the almost orthogonal
vectors in the D dimensional space so V1
to VMS are almost orthogonal meaning
that their inner product is less than is
just order of log M over d square root
of log m/
D and we know that there exists just
exponentially in the uh many
them okay and then it's easy to see that
any L1 spanner of size less than M even
just you just ignore one of them uh need
to have L1 Norm for coefficient Vector
at least Omega of square root D over
log the reason is that because just
everything I mean if you write it in the
canonical form of uh this inner product
I mean all of them has just a small
value so the L1 Norm should be large
actually we can show that this uh what
you get from the L2 spanner and just
doing the uh Kush Schwartz you get
actually the matching B here you get
this uh this bounds on the L1 or with
just order
D
vectors so basically this is optimal and
again using this the holder in quality
and the the lower bound that we have for
p equal to one and the the bound that we
have for p equal 2 we can also get this
uh this uh bounds for any P between one
and
two okay so we cannot hope to get the
norm better than D over login to this
power and we have the upper bound that
get D to the p over 2 p minus
2 and it's about the norm the size is
still 3D here at least I mean we have
the side 3D or two 2D existentially
okay
um and for p greater than two is just
simply follow from the L2 spanner right
you can just use the2 spanner and this
is still size is um has size less than
3D okay so I want I want to summarize
here
and and maybe just mention few open
question so basically what did was just
the analysis of a simple local search
algorithm for volumetric
expander and I mean it's important I
mean have tons of application from the
Bandit linear on multi-armed
Bandit um or online linear optimization
Matrix sketching and so on so and
hopefully you can find
more and that was the open question that
was uh raised by hazan and caring they
show that there was a 12 times the upper
bound and they show a lower bound of D+
one so we make it down to 3D and
actually 2D as you mentioned
existentially so but yeah it's still a
interesting question to see what uh can
be done
here and there was actually some gaps
for other Norms that I show it was but
basically not on the size on the
guarantee of the the norm of the
coefficient vector so it's interesting
question of to see what's what's
actually the right value
there and I hope I mean that you can
find some nice application of this uh
object in design algorithm in different
areas and that was mainly uh the purpose
of my
talk uh thank you if you have any
[Applause]
question any more questions for Ellie
I have I can go through some mve but
yeah I don't how much time do we
have I have a
question like if I just had a set of
vectors where every Vector is one on the
first entry and then on the rest of the
entries it's like either it's like a one
on the first entry and a one somewhere
else or a negative one somewhere
else it feels like a case where like 2D
would be optim like if you thought are
these cases like this D I don't know D
plus1 sounds like a really weak is there
a chance 2D is just the best you can
do I mean I could we could take it
offline I just wonder if you thought
about these lower Bounds at all or not
actually we haven't thought about it so
but u i mean the the lower bound that
for instance the things that's been
known for maybe uh B also somewhat uh
suggesting that 2D might be the right
answer yeah that's that makes sense yeah
okay cool
yeah um so at the beginning you said
that for the L Infinity Norm we do know
that D is possible right yeah any do we
have any understanding what happens
between two and infinity then uh so I
mean everything that I mentioned for two
will apply for there right so
forance 2D existentially exist we know
we have it I mean by the guarantee of L2
you have guarantee for anything larger
right oh gotcha right right okay so
that's that's clear but yeah in terms of
the lower B if forance what's the right
answer we don't know
yeah again the same question sounds good
thank
you
questions
so we now have lunch and please be back
by 2
p.m.